Keep in mind that in order to thoroughly
benefit from
this morning or
hadith or
that the idea behind this it's geared
towards having
something to reflect on and think about
throughout your day. So you hear this
narration. Every day we take one
narration
and this should peique your curiosity.
It should be something that you work
into your contemplation and thought
throughout the day. Maybe you have some
questions about it. Maybe it warrants
some further research or investigation.
Maybe it's something that you can find
applications for throughout your day or
night, etc.
We don't want to be in a situation where
we are constantly receiving new
knowledge, new narrations, new
information, and having it just kind of
wash over us and go off into oblivion.
Why do I say this? Well, the reason I
say this is because we have been trained
for exactly that
with social media with the break neck
speed at which information comes at us
every moment. We have basically become
unable to hold any coherent thought or
train of thought for any extended period
of time or dwell with our thoughts for
an afternoon or an evening. rather it's
something that we hear and then it is
quickly dismissed and goes off into
oblivion. So we don't want that to
occur with the prophet Muhammad's
words. We're in the first chapter of
the chapter regarding sincerity and
holding a coherent intention in all
actions and all speech and all inward
and outward
states of being.
[Silence]
will be aim.
He narrates here a narration on the
authority of
Isa. Hera
a in the Arabic language is ebu
something or something. Right? Abu or it
could be a nickname. It could be the
eldest child. It could be a person
that doesn't have any children. It could
even be a child. Even the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam gave
or
they had a very young child that passed
away while he was still in his
adolescence.
He had given him a nickname this.
He had given him a kuna. And so a kuna
is something that the Arabs would have.
Our prophet sallallah.aii wasallam his
kuna was Abdul Kasim Abulass,
his wife, she didn't have any children.
She didn't have any boys. She didn't
have any girls. She didn't have any
children that died in their youth. She
didn't have any children at all. And so,
how did she get her ka?
It's because one of her sisters had a
child and named it Abdullah. And she was
then given this as her maternal aunt.
And so she says so her is
Abu Bakr's daughter.
She said the messenger of Allah Sam
said
a time will come and this is one of the
signs of the hour one of the major signs
of the hour near the end of time when
the Ka will be attacked by an army. And
while this army is traveling through the
deserts of modern day Saudi Arabia,
traveling through the desert there in
Arab on their way to demolish the Kaa
and infiltrate and conquer Mecca.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will cause the
earth to swallow every single one of
them. Every single one of them.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam said
the earth will be made to swallow the
first of them and the last of them. All
of them. And so
she said, "Oh messenger of Allah, how
will it be that the earth will be made
to swallow every one of them when there
are amongst them servants and people who
have joined their caravan but don't know
where the army is headed? They're not
involved in what the army is headed for.
So you have to understand the situation
here. Imagine that when a a traveling
caravan goes through the desert or what
have you, it's not something you can
just travel to on your own. It's not
today in modern travel. Back then
and at the time when this will occur,
you see a major caravan, an army,
whatever it is, traveling. Many people
would join along in that travel having
no idea where that army is headed to or
what business they have. They're either
going in the same direction or they are
merchants that are buying and selling
with this army or they are servants that
have been brought against their will.
And so seemingly the punishment of Allah
for this army attacking the Kaa is that
all of them will be destroyed. But this
justice of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala it
how is it going to be just when when
those amongst them haven't earned that
destruction their intention was not to
attack the capital. So notice here why
this narration is in this chapter
because of intention intention. And so
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
explained to her he said
He said all of them, he reiterated it.
All of them, every one of them will be
destroyed.
But then on the day of judgment, they
will be resurrected and judged based on
their intention. Based on their
intention. And so here we have a general
punishment.
However, intention is the only that is
going to save some and be the
destruction of others is their
intention. Their intention. But what
else do we learn from this? We also
learn from this that good intentions
will not save you from the punishment of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala necessarily.
If you
sit in the company or
are if you are in the company of a
people when Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
destroys them you will be destroyed with
them. That punishment will envelop you
as along with them.
Yes, a person will be saved when they're
resurrected based on their intention.
However, this won't save a person from
the destruction of this life. So it
becomes very important for us to always
check our surroundings and check the
company that we keep because we could be
we could be lumped in with the guilty
and the innocent are lumped in with the
guilty because of the company that they
keep.
What is